have to be honest about what is  happening out there and I would love to  be able to say that our my colleagues in  the ambulance services and in emergency  departments could say that we can offer  safe Care at the moment but the the  truth is that we are unable to offer the  safe and effective care that we would  like to provide we simply can't look  after people effectively in ambulance  car Parks we certainly can't look after  them if we can't get an ambulance to  them and it's impossible to look after  patients properly in corridors in  hospitals so we we really we're capable  of providing some of the best care in  the world in our emergency departments  but we cannot do that at the moment